bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous alors emmanuel macron qui est de
retour sur le terrain et s'auto félicie
de la stratégie de déconfinement
pourtant encore un petit peu fou oui
alors s'auto féliciter c'est un d une
des grandes qualités d' emmanuel macron
il est toujours très content de ce qu'il
fait tout comme le gouvernement
et c'est vrai que on l'a vu devant des
élèves un client pourtant poser la
question alors est-ce que ça va depuis
la claque que vous avez prises en mise
en scène encore une fois cette fois ci
dans une école
et puis c'est cette déambulation du
promeneur de l'elysée pour dire que tout
va très bien madame la marquise et qu'il
a géré cette crise sanitaire de manière
exceptionnelle comparé au reste des
leaders mondiaux et que lui décidément
le meilleur quelle chance nous avons
mais en réalité tout ça est très floue
comme vous venez de le dire à la fois
sur la le rythme de la vaccination n'a
pu vraiment les chiffres sur les
premiers vaccinés puis ceux qui ont la
vaccination total mais également sur ses
dates qui ont totalement sauter la fin
du couvre-feu
là la fin de toutes les les barrières
qui avait parce que finalement la
bamboche a gagné trois jours de suite
que les jeunes se réunissaient sur les
pelouse en plein coeur de paris
et là la police ne peut plus rien faire
et puis des remontées de terrain qui
disait évidemment les gens en ont assez
les restaurateurs notamment qui ouvrait
et qui voyait bien que à 23 heures c'est
impossible de faire partir les gens pour
qu'ils rentrent chez eux donc il a fallu
céder finalement à la volonté populaire
qui était de d'arrêter avec ces mesures
de restriction non pas sanitaire ahmed
de restriction liberticide qui n'ont
rien à voir avec le contrôle de ta virus
c'est la fin du masque en extérieur
aussi et pourtant ça fait des mois que
l'on sait que le masque en extérieur ne
sert à rien dans la plupart des
situations quand vous êtes seul dans une
rue où très peu nombreux dans une rue
évidemment le masque ne sert à rien mais
il fallait quand même le tenir pour que
l'exécutif ne perde pas la face passe à
ces mesures de privation des libertés
puis dernière aberration qui tombe le
masque des plus jeunes les enfants dans
les cours de récréation à 6 ans est bien
là aussi il tombe il a fallu quelques
heures de décalage pour qu'ils se
rendent compte du décalage énorme entre
la volonté des politiques liberticides
et
la volonté de liberté des populations
qui n'en peuvent plus finalement de ces
mesures dont on peut critiquer le
bien-fondé scientifique puisque nous
n'avons aucune preuve aujourd'hui d'un
couvre-feu plus efficace à 19h à 21h à
23h ou pas du tout en l'occurrence le
pas du tout que nous permettent de vivre
un été des confiné alors après certains
sont déjà en train de nous parler de
quatrième vague 1 reste à savoir si elle
arrivera ou pas mais pour ce qui est de
la stratégie d' emmanuel macron elle a
été cette fois-ci dicté par la rue mais
la question qu'on peut se poser dexi la
communication présidentielle at elle
pour objectif de pousser les candidats
rêvent aux régionales ou est ce une
surenchère de sortie de crise alors
c'est vrai que en ce moment emmanuel
macron et partout on le voit à tous les
sommaires il prend la parole sur tous
les sujets aujourd'hui ils discutaient
poésie littérature et peinture avec
fabrice luchini allant même jusqu'à le
comparer rimbaud un peintre classique
donc tout est possible pour le promeneur
de l'elysée il ya un côté psychédélique
dans cette communication qui veut
toucher tous les publics
tout le temps à la fois les publics les
plus jeunes c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'il lève les restrictions sanitaires
c'est un peu dans l'idée de dire ça y
est vous avez gagné
je vous ai entendu les puits il faut ne
pas oublier les régionales alors
emmanuel macron s'en défend il dit bien
qu'il ne veut surtout pas interférer
dans les élections régionales mais il
est le seul aujourd'hui qui peut prendre
la parole de cette façon là qu'on parle
aux ministres qui ont un devoir de
réserve
vu que nous sommes dans une semaine
électorale donc clairement il est là
pour pousser les candidatures des
candidats lrm à la fois pour montrer
qu'ils existent les faire connaître
certains sont encore en déficit de
notoriété publique
donc ça permet de donner pousser et
d'affaiblir soient les candidats aient
l'air typiquement xavier bertrand qui
est une cible dans la région nord pour
pour le laisser y est de l'affaiblir
face à un rassemblent nationale qui est
très fort avec l'envoi de ministres
comme monsieur dupont moretti mise de la
justice qui passe tous ses week-ends
maintenant à faire campagne bien habillé
pour expliquer qu'il est là pour les
habitants de la région est donc
clairement il y à là cette volonté de
reprendre la main et d'essayer de
pousser ces candidatures sans le dire
parce que le score de la république en
marche risque d'être calamiteux
également pour ces régionales donc si
les vitres à une bérézina comme pour les
municipales
ce ne sera pas non plus un plébiscite
populaire qu'est la jambe a finalement
celui emmanuel macron est ce qu'il reste
pour reprendre une formule 1 est ce
qu'il reste le maître des horloges
alors c'est ainsi qu'il s'était présenté
lors de son élection 1 en disant c'est
moi qui décide et puis très vite le jeu
s'est déréglé avec la sphère benalla par
exemple sur la place de la contrescarpe
est là toute la machine s'est déréglée
il a voulu être le maître les horloges
avec la réforme des retraites en
utilisant le 49 3 en allant là encore
contre l'avis des partenaires sociaux
il a voulu être le maître des horloges
contre les gilets jaunes avec ce grand
débat qui a privatisé la parole
finalement où il a été un monologue est
partout en france et empêcher les
cahiers de doléances de devenir
finalement des réelles cahier de
doléances donc oui clairement son agenda
personnel est celui de maintenant donner
le pouls donné le tempo de 2022 et
d'assurer qu'il puisse rentrer en
campagne le plus tard possible et avec
le meilleur bilan possible hélas toute
cette communication frénétique qu'on a
vu ces derniers jours c'est d'assurer
que dans l'esprit des français il
restera comme le sauveur du pays et le
président qui a le mieux géré la crise
sanitaire même s'il y a plus de cent dix
mille morts même si on a menti le
gouvernement a menti sur les masques au
début de cette crise même si la
vaccination au début de la campagne a
été un fiasco
même si il y a encore beaucoup de fous
comme je le disais sur ceux des
confinement qui ressemble très fort hood
et confinement de 2020 où ça a été un
grand lâcher prise pendant tout l'été
là on a l'impression qu'il ya des dates
que tout ça est très réglée olivier
verrons nous dit que les discothèques
rouvriront en juillet mais non on a
l'impression que ça y est c'est fini
pour deux mois trois mois
et puis comme je vous le disais certains
nous parlent déjà de quatrième vague et
peut-être qu emmanuel macron a déjà en
tête
l'horlogerie de la rentrée durant
campagne qui sera évidemment à la
rentrée de septembre pour tous les
candidats les nouveaux candidats qui
vont se déclarer à ce moment là et puis
clairement une fois les régionales
passées que certains parlent aujourd'hui
d'un remaniement ministériel
ça reste à voir mais il y a des noms qui
circulent et il se pourrait évidemment
qu'en fonction des scores de la
république en marche le goût
ornements change de tête échanges même
de ministre pendant un temps pour
préparer la dernière année qui sera une
année de campagne démarre merci beaucoup
alexis poulain d'avoir été avec nous